this guy's just getting started is
rookie season with the Atlanta Hawks
averaging 18.7 almost eight assists per
game and he's a Trey young who joins us
on the program by the way his last game
he hit the buzzer beater to beat the
76ers scoring 32 points with 11 assists
Trey good morning how are you I'm doing
I'm doing great I'm just curious
that you know what rookies usually hit
that rookie wall you seem to be getting
better at the end of the season why is
that
uh I need for me maybe that's my rookie
wallet at the beginning and I went over
it really yeah I really just think that
it's it's for me now I'm second and
third somebody's in the fourth time and
now I know a little bit more about I
mean the guards and the type of players
I'm playing against and the type of
distance is I'm saying anything like
that so I think the game is slowing down
for me just because of things like that
when was your welcome to the NBA moment
who were you guarding where you went or
they were guarding you I had a couple I
mean my first not everybody could say
their first game in the NBA is in nice
and square garden that was I mean it's a
real surreal day it's a real moments of
me I had a chance to generate a
game-winner in LA in Staples Center and
just LeBron and the first time I played
him so I think probably that moment it
was probably my welcome to a moment have
you guarded Oh James have you tried to
guard James Harden this year yeah yeah I
saw it goes on what's that like that's
the city garden you don't know what
you're gonna do what he's gonna step
back or try to go around you you got a I
mean try your best to can test can test
every shot it just feels like he's
unstoppable Trey
ya know on that on that offensive end I
mean he's probably second to none as far
as the ability to score at any time
sometimes you gotta hope he's having an
off night
as far as shooting did you fill out a
bracket for the NC double-a tournament
yeah I did I did I said that - okay how
far did you have Oklahoma going my
unbiased one or bias one unbiased I'm
biased I out of I see Adam fallen to
Virginia Virginia this is too good this
year
okay I see but the bigger thing about
that I have them wonders at all so like
so good good since they beat us as they
went it off wait you have Virginia we
winning it all yeah as Virginia won it
all were you rooting for or against Duke
last night for Duke
toward you I like seeing like you know
the guys play so they're getting burnt
early in the tournament
I think it would be fun did Duke recruit
you yeah they did and they kind of I
mean Sue's out but early on took a visit
out there and everything yeah well so
did they did they stop recruiting you or
did they realized that maybe you were
gonna stay close to home in Oklahoma
yeah I think that's more what it was
they said I was going to take either
closer home or end up at Kentucky and go
that route but that's what it was I mean
I had I had an offer just capable was
one who recruited me you know and the
Coach K so yeah that's really what it
with them are you allowed to shoot
whenever you want to I don't know I
don't know that answer well you've been
told not to shoot and you have the green
light to shoot whenever you want yeah
yeah yeah yeah
I'm just tryna make the right place I
don't suit every time who has deeper
range than you in the NBA that's a good
question I don't know I think I mean
Steph Steph as you know a lot of range
Damian Lillard has a lot of range
no guys for sure I think I think they
are out there probably only two I could
think of what was it like though playing
against Golden State
first time it was great it was kind of
surreal because growing up I mean I was
always I mean obviously I almost a lot
of stuff but I mean I grew up in OKC
where I was able to to be I mean pretty
close to KD so knowing him throughout
high school and when I was younger I
playing him for the first time was
pretty cool and pretty surreal so
playing against Steph was obviously
pretty cool but I mean KD I'm seeing him
playing it was kind of surreal what do
you miss about college I think the
atmosphere I mean I went to the the
first round again when I
Oklahoma played Ole Miss and just the
atmosphere I mean you don't get that
type out and then Billy West I mean I
embrace the the signs that there's other
students I should work with bringing to
the games chance and different things
and over like the overrated chance all
of those those things that I mean
college basketball environments bring to
the game that you don't if I see every
night in the NBA you see him in some
arenas but I mean that atmosphere in
college is something different can you
explain to me when you go down the floor
like at what point do you realize that
you may just pull up and shake it like
what do you see that you just go okay
you're gonna give me this and then
you're going to take the jumper I think
all the way back cuz I mean for me if I
was if I'm doing it
hit one or two threes already in the
game and I'm I'm feeling good if I come
down and we get a rebound and I'm
pushing in transition and the defender
my defender karma is in the at the
three-point line I mean there's a good
chance I'm pulling up some pretty far
how many dunks do you have this year he
wrote 0.3 what are you doing
I know I know I could clown some very
long time about that Duncan he's waiting
for my first Duncan again I mean Vince
is my age tray and he's still done him
he's not human
can you get a dunk before the end of the
regular season
we can try I can try but you can dunk
right yeah I can't okay okay thank you
yeah because if you one of my favorite
shoe that I taught you about this was a
mo Williams he told him about a how many
games and points he scored his career
but never never done I think John
Stockton even had a dunk tray in his
career so yeah just a little bit and I I
think you got to change the spelling of
your name Y T r ey no no my name is so
different I like it
no you're trying your shoe trays you're
three no that's right the way it is
different unique I like that mmm I like
it I like it
hey congrats on this season it's it's
the Arian pretty lofty company there and
I know it's you and Luka going down to
the wire for Rookie of the Year so did
you guys ever talk about that when you
guys met at the all-star game now we
talked a little bit about it but not too
much no Lucas for a little bit we met
there's all seasons - all season and at
the trash and in rookie
and any restated numbers we talk I mean
ever so often so we saw thunder say
about the wreck it yourself it's this is
this other thing so he's a good dude but
uh yeah we think on test a little bit
well congrats on the season so far and
good luck with Ricky of the Year honors
great to catch up with you again
yes sir appreciated thank you for having
me on again
alright that's uh Trey young for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]